hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play or should I
say markiplier sucks at dota2 and I'm
here with purged from purged gamers you
can find them in the description below
he is he won't say to himself but he's
probably one of the better dota players
in the world I won't say exactly how
much because he said you know you don't
say how much but he's really really good
and I'm gonna really really piss him off
with how badly I'm gonna play so
introduce yourself please
hey guys my name is perch I do
introductory videos to dota 2 so if you
guys want to learn how to play the game
I'm the guy to go to and that's about it
I sometimes cast my free time and I have
a lot of guides and other things so lots
of learning materials if you guys want
to try this game out mm-hmm it just hit
open beta or hit open actually the game
finally launched after like two years of
beta so oh I did exciting time oh I
thought it was always out my way oh man
you caught it you caught it within a
week yes I mean alright great good for
me okay but I bet purge has never met a
guy or tried to teach a guy like me how
to play them remember we're playing
against hard BOTS
right hard bots yes that's right yes
just hard bots because you once I'm too
Pro seeker or at least I've got purge
here on my back to try to defend me when
I screw up so at least the knowledge is
can be good we'll see how your mechanics
turns out I'm not really sure how this
is gonna go so agility and you're gonna
do slark you can just type in his name
right now wait if [ __ ] should bring you
to the did I actually like selects Allah
I think I just looked at his card and
wait hang out we're huh where is he he
was an agility guy right the green thing
no I just ran Damir Oh Oh God is that
for a reset for real ok wait hang on
alright you're just gonna lose some gold
from that that's how do what how do I
all right press control that should
bring you to like oh there it is okay
there's slark okay got him got it got it
okay you lost 100 gold from this but
it's a guy already I'm not even in the
game you randomly repacked what act
that's cheating pretty good okay all
right whatever sure I cool so you're
gonna buy some items quick go to the
shop cool I've got 503 Grohl he's got a
lot um it's a lesson you should have but
you can make this work sounds great you
got a you got a support warlock here
this guy will hopefully not take your
lest it so your goal is basically just
to grab every last sip that you can
and alarm up to the point where you can
snowball and opulently goes I mean the
perfect representation of what a
snowball is you get bigger and bigger
and stronger and stronger by killing
people okay
amassing their mass to your body okay
what would I do one now do I eat them I
mean technically yeah your uh vocals on
them and they're good I hope you turn
the body into gold and then use the Gulf
items whose actual ingestion nice cool
where are you
I'm spectating so I'm just watching your
every move wait no I I've just thought I
[ __ ] up I did something wrong I
pounced and I thought it was a select
your never mind nope it is it is not
it's a skill shot so didn't tell me it
was a skill shot didn't you should not
Oh attack by the way and you're also
taking two mistakes right off the bed
already
you got a support warlock he's gonna
heal you Josh so basically just come up
with a creepy way whenever there's a
last hit and then you got to run away
for a bit okay I see some heroes over
there should i attack them nope not all
[ __ ] Jim gonna kill anybody yet [ __ ]
[ __ ] I attacked him can I pound some
where hang on yeah if you want to I
meant I'm gonna try Barada hit him I
almost got him did I get him
Eddy don't stop I get him am I gonna let
him [ __ ] it Bob
oh I didn't I didn't get the girl a
skill it's okay I thought I was gonna
get the last gun that's uh I apologize
for getting too excited okay the cow is
bad yeah yeah you're not gonna get any
of these last it's just back up and wait
for the I'm gonna pounce at our um okay
haha I missed the tower I went right
over it didn't you're so lucky of a
warlock this guy's just like healing you
constantly well thank you is that that's
not you right you wouldn't heal me
constantly definitely not oh you like
noob stop feeding HP I used that to eat
a tree no how does that work how do I
eat a tree um I really don't know but
it's been in the game for over so okay
why are everything left click on the
stove shield in the shop okay it'll show
the tree of what oh I see
okay got it Oh boom perfect alright now
go kill people I'm so good so boom like
that just keep in mind that does damage
to you as well so you don't really want
to spend this eel stinking peeps again
well what's the point of that are you
watching me buddy
watching me suck as your
owning it up and wherever you are a QCs
as well it's just okay I'm gonna route
out a pouch oh no oh no the tower hit me
a lot it kind of hurt well there he goes
wait hang on oh oh oh I see what you
mean hang on
I'm going for it God no no too much no I
don't yet good good call I lied you did
the right thing what is this yeah see a
go see see I've got I've got gamer n6
not a lot of people realize that I'm
actually just acting like I'm bad at
games okay
Herbert great spin yeah good yeah yeah
we killed you got oh no oh you got away
okay he's got boots you're not gonna
kill him but you know the tango that's
good mm cuz that's gonna call someone of
HP okay dude I do also do Herbert
no no wait that wasn't the right high
key sorry I'm gonna but then I decided
against it what do I do tell me I'm
perfect again yeah you're doing a great
job I'm gonna need a lot from how to
other place like right now haha don't
turn splosions go for that night maybe
maybe not ah no okay go shut up dad
hello yeah I don't think what do I do
dead oh it hurts it's dark in here
so your first time dying yes how does it
feel it feels horrible you're ready for
the next 5,000 good it's gonna happen a
lot all right well I got to run all the
way back to the bot Lane ah I was a
story to tell we were waiting story to
tell well I was I was kind of I was
preparing for my career in dota where
I'd be the only player that never died
in his entire career but oh sorry
hey I'm one in one that all that's all
that matters
you get your give to sis what're you
talking about you even gotten to kill
yet well uh oh yeah that's right well
just poke a hole in all my dreams
something's gotta tell you no I'm just
doing you a favor really gonna find out
eventually you said I was perfect
flawless unstoppable I'm in a possum
oh no no you went away it happened you
almost kill them I almost did you can if
you stand there and cast your dark pact
again you can almost killed a guy like
just word
dude all right now back out I don't know
if you can pounce invisible people you
try just go all right you missed okay
try do it again duck back duck by I
don't a rope go get him
oh you got I did my god um hang on I
need to celebrate first menu yeah okay
I'm done though perfect I did good I did
good
give me a pat on the head I done good I
stop I'll give you a thing on up
anything on you yeah I'm gonna circle
you with white lines you can't see this
but are you gonna draw paint are you
drawing a penis I mean I definitely
could are you I'm gonna drop can I draw
how do i how do I do that
I'm gonna draw hold control and you can
draw on the madam Shonda big penis there
we go get some hairs you you know how to
play matchmaking now that's literally
though that's all that happens you're
missing a lot of last hits way drawing
dicks episode Hey it's very important
you let me have my time I haven't done
it in drunk minecraft and what I gotta
do it now
I'm trying it is hard right now dicks
dicks right now yes all right sit her
jigs I'm sorry I messed up the deck damn
it I messed up the dick I messed up the
last hit I'm just I'm terrible at this
press it
Shh fast you are hello I'm going for it
hello yeah
ah hi what's the wrong way dude
Jenna Danny good good this okay
hi expertly maneuvered I I'm at sign bro
haha it was a shock and awe tactic they
were shocked at how awful I was ha ha
I'm Todd under Cohen Turner when we're
oh oh sorry I didn't even I didn't even
know that was a result of aha miss okay
Oh Oh run bought the Samba the world
like you might give you mana fingers
cause she's got our king boots just ask
him like take them please please warlock
ooh
warlock he looks so good in your robes
have you been working out I see you're
looking really fit could you please just
give me a little man hook it on my knees
oh good now he's not doing it he's not
going for it I don't know I'm just huh
I'm pretty sexy I mean I'm my voice it's
nice and seductive I bet everyone who's
watching this right now is like Oh
you my mana I'll give you all night mana
I'm a busta star down LJ on my face will
you
oh so close I'm gonna get her I'm gonna
watch double damage damage dress
no I'm stunned ed something happens so
no no done GOP who no okay I'm dead I I
died a long time ago so you got shackled
which is a stun and then you got stunned
again and you died I know what happened
everyone knows what happened it's okay
I'm the student you're the master you
should probably run you know definitely
about allow ow
I'm know I'm like I'm tough uh you lose
face boots boots guilty ulti ulti bad
what did it do to me
Alissa's all the next time when you get
shot you should probably run away I was
running away this an advanced gaming
concept but oh oh is that sass I hear
over there really really bad I got on
that yes yes aggregor oh come on
ah anyways I'm done I'm gonna die ah
wait ran too far
ah die run far enough just you'd left
you team oh well I had full confidence
in their abilities to succeed I will
totally show him what is up and what is
up is my boot up his ass
see okay so oh my dad's owning oh [ __ ]
your team's owning yeah yeah new team go
okay fighting that's not I'm going gonna
go for it I love it too early but it's
okay uh-huh yeah are you you did
something
I did I did something indeed kaboom
you're like you're doing stuff I don't
even have to tell you anymore what is
this
Oh pushing just keep going that's the
closest thing to a compliment I've got
another thing that's not I I am sir are
you over here to go fight her so bad
yeah that works and I'm running I'm
hiding in a corner I'm
armed and angry well I'm not I'm getting
scared
make it like killing these guys I'll try
hang on watch it watch these epic [ __ ]
again moves aah
oh those those dumb no God he told you
about really dumb I'm I am invited so
you purchased the robe of the Magi and
when they all three pieces come together
it'll create a new item what that's
awesome oh it's magic I don't know penis
in celebration of that that's awesome
run south and leap I'm right uh your
courier might be dead um no it's okay
wait oh that's my courier oh I can't
wait go fight I'm uh
I'm gonna you I'm gonna wait no the mall
I'm at yeah I did it you didn't see I
was totally in there I'm murdering
everyone in their face it was pretty
awesome I have to admit for me and I'm
pretty skilled it would pre mate I am
honestly like really terrified to play
with you the next game I are not gonna
lie right now I would be too and I I put
out a challenge to all the viewers
watching this right now there's a new
king of the mountain on the dota scene
markiplier surname challenge me any day
jumper Monday through Hyundai killin guy
I think I did Ondine wow I am hurting
ulti I I don't know why all teams I'm
hiding in a corner you were so close to
dying I know I was there
you landed one of those kill to cool it
she's gotta HP I'll kill the we're
getting yeah ah a gum ulti oh my god oh
my god
come on BAE ah I'm awesome okay good you
did it nice so I just clear yes I did it
I saw the night um and then I bought it
yay they bought back which is bad cuz
you told me though it's bad we're gonna
kill this tower which is good what's a
little money hey Lorna wait where was I
where the hell am I
I didn't even my gosh ah-ha what I'm
drawing a big middle finger to that cuz
I couldn't see where it was because
well I kinda looks like I drew a penis
with four balls but that's okay it was a
middle finger I mean why what was that
oh there's no way you would've been
successful on that guy oh oh really not
possible oh really
absolutely not possible real we could
try that next game I guess but it's just
simply not gonna work there should
you're saying I'm not good enough to
play that care you're right yeah that's
definitely what I'm saying you
wouldn't've been successful oh I mean
you're pretty good but I'm missing
messing up slark it if they're not gonna
make okay uncle work I like how you just
slide in the insults with the
compliments or rather the compliments
with all the enzyme you're doing
something yeah
well I'm gonna go no you're not getting
away from me drum drum was it do
bangbang happy birthday you helped a lot
or they kill all right go fight nothing
fight oh I pound somewhere whoa what the
why is that guy do oh I I did that I did
something what did I do
did you see it mr. spectator man okay oh
you should help you I'm trying I'm gonna
rough I gotta good I got you guys I also
know I believe the answers all we're
gonna get we're up yeah yeah yeah all
right the bear ass oh nice oh [ __ ] fight
where's a boat wait whoa okay brother Lu
I I did something there I left and I
missed but I almost had it
this guy that's just like looking at you
yeah he's a guide you doing he's just
going to die absolute me Lulu yeah weird
me mad it's okay I'm gonna hide in my
corner we're no one can see me and I'm
gonna heal up you'll notice that I put
sound effects whenever I do my attacks
it helps do more damage in case you
didn't know here's a protip for you note
well I mean maybe not more damage but
like definitely a lot more strength than
oh yeah there's definitely yeah it
really helps to scream at you but I want
to see like a couple professional
players in big tournaments just like you
can see them in their little glass booth
and they're just gonna just thank you
you might go oh I wasn't even paying
attention excellence why didn't huh they
did Tom to me they're doing things to me
that I didn't want
63 seconds for a brand new player like a
brand brand-new player I'm not doing
okay hey you doing okay okay all right
that's all that I can oh four oh my god
we're gonna win we're gonna win I need
to be there at least once drums I don't
know drums bagging it boom oh I was
there in spirit that's all that matters
yeah I mean haha hell yeah
all right I did it I won my first game
against hard BOTS wombo combo so they
really did have a lot of wombo combo
though do you know that means no idea
that's okay just say it all the time and
wombo combo I'm just going to game hey
wombo combo bottom wha-wha-wha combo
they will don't understand double combo
wombo combo those guys in the force
it won't perfect you should definitely
try to get into the pro scene
immediately as fast as possible to try
to get picked up I'm sure somebody else
your talent someone watch me okay oh
yeah yeah that's cool all right so
anyway thank you so much perch for
teaching me how to be awesome you're
awesome for being patient with my
horrible gameplay so any day yeah give
your sign out say goodbye to everyone
then I'll do mine okay thanks everyone
for watching if you want to check out
markiplier its youtube.com slash
markiplier if I'm not mistaken yep Oh
markiplier game but if you search for
markiplier you'll find me okay do that
guys that's it okay then thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to find more of the unedited stuff
this was the edited version obviously if
you want to see the whole thing go to
purged gamers uh purged gamers that's it
on youtube search for them you'll find
him there great he's one of the best
dota players out there maybe not the
best but one of the best definitely so I
do it thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
I
turn
what
i'ma be
so
buzz
by the Firebird fees we go once go out
into the middle of the night they could
kill me
nibble my